they are too funny guys dumb people town
podcasts they are co-host of it with
Daniel Van Kirk that's their latest
venture that you can catch them in the
Mayan theater locally in Los Angeles
California later on this week the Largo
as well before they go to a big tent
country in Bloomington Illinois none
other than Indiana good to see you nice
to see you rich always job on the dress
yeah you were fantastic I thank you guys
really fun to watch some amazing
storylines I mean the draft and then the
fallout of the draft you know what I
mean like we were talking with Josh
Rosen and we were saying his trajectory
if you think about go back to last
year's draft is the story of Passover if
we may I mean if we stay with us here
stays you he gets he's gets lost in the
desert we don't know what's gonna happen
is wandering essentially in the desert
he's doubting his future after being the
chosen one after being the chosen one
right yes lost in the desert and then he
finds his way to the place where all
Jews settled Miami retire they're like
so I think we're talking about like he
like we were all talking about like this
could be the first trip pick in last
year's draft like people like Baker
Mayfield why didn't you take Josh Rosen
so like he he still hasn't shown us what
he can show us agreed I think he might
it really enjoy his time in Miami and
and that's a that's not a bad team well
the crazy thing is that dolphins are
already saying that he needs to he needs
to compete for the job with Ryan
Fitzpatrick so I saw a picture of Fitz
and logically not Jewish just in case
you're wondering at home not Jewish not
a Jew Ryan so it wasn't their pictures
circulating around and you know Brock
when you might be he was looking he was
looking at zekiel Elliot Laurie the
explanation
what was the question was he's got seven
kids now so he's too short of rivers
yeah and too many birthdays and he was
loading up on a case what he sent mean
to me if I saw it Ryan Fitzpatrick at
Burning Man I'd be like yeah yeah but
the way I mean we were talk about the
draft no one's talking about the fact
that Sebastian Janikowski announced his
retirement
and what a grit I'm happy for the guy
finally he can just let himself go put
on a cup all the guardrails are off
showing a prostitution ring run by Toni
Kukoc honey Kukoc was part of a
prostitution ring yes and he actually
did I mean it was him and another person
another person so they actually keyed it
a perfect try go yeah it was like a
three-ring circus and refused to go
figure there I might have been involved
with the draft back then you know yeah
it's funny with Rosen going to Miami we
were talking off air mm-hmm because this
is the sort of conversation you know you
can't go down the Godfather Part II to
worm oh yeah that we wanted to have a
video of Hyman Roth who always loved
watching football in the afternoons as
you know yes yes to see what he would
think of his reaction Rosen coming to to
Miami he may be extent by the way just
in that movie like I just wanted him to
get air conditioning I was like why
arrow when we were like okay with being
uncomfortable right like as not anymore
we can't handle anything so what else
did you write texted you and I text him
I was coming here today since his best
to you max Greenfield okay as a fan of
this show we enjoyed our time with him I
are just a huge Giants fan so freaking
out he is he's like I'm happy you said
what we said which is like wait James
Dolan owns the Giants now like what are
they doing what are they doing I mean
they made they're making worse decisions
than James James Dolan who is in a blues
band the gravitational pull of the
dolmen wormhole I
when I went down one at the you know you
know the Giants are like to kind of be
like if the Giants were in your fantasy
league they'd be like hey I gotta take a
kicker first points plenty of em in the
last round so there's let's take them
north
it's just easy it is low-hanging fruit
with the Giants right now it kind of is
what we have no idea this could be great
I mean I hope you have no idea who does
zero
I would love ideas okay the only problem
is that think again the the only
confidence level that the Giants fans
can have it's like okay who's the guy
who's making these choices right and his
track record in recent days with Giants
fans and also what he did in Carolina
just you know what we're just gonna take
Josh Norman and let him walk
yes we're gonna resistant cuz I'm gonna
be you know I'm gonna be petulant or
he's being petulant I'll show him I'll
just let him walk for nothing and make
his king's ransom okay in the division
where he is right right exactly then
Landon Collins goes to that same team
then he chooses this quarterback from
Dave Browns
alma mater hmm and Dave Brown again for
fans you may not know is it was a
supplemental draft choice that Giants
fans hoped would bridge the success from
Parcells
onward right so all of that together you
put it in a hopper and it comes out who
the hell is this guy and what's he doing
he could really be terrific what what if
he is great and I hope he's great and I
would love to see now Vegas always has a
line for everything like this what if
he's more successful than Zion
Williamson what if like he we all know
well I say I saw Simon Williamson do
like a gender-reveal he dunked it that's
all that basically said what the gender
was going to be I'm like should he be
doing dunks like for nothing right now
like as this ankle but could it have
been that that company that had tio or
somebody read off something oh yeah
cameo is a atio doing something suspect
for a company to Romano much money that
does not sound
seems odd time he's out there watching
everything during his Hall of Fame
induction instead of me but I think
Giants fans would take Daniel Jones
being more successful than Allah
Abdul Nabi Riley you want to choose Duke
basketball players would rather be right
here let's just you know uh it is one of
those things where Dez Mac did max or
does he know any Giants fans who have
put the eye test on watched a Duke
football like who even football game no
and did not go to Duke not a lot of
people but including people I think the
argument is I think the argument is
though even if he turns out to be good
yes he still would have been around
later so use that first pick for some
other high value cuz they were trying to
make the case that like he's gonna be
gone right be gone about like like who
drew luck just the the Broncos kept
trading down Andrew Luck was still there
well I'm running the risk that Mike Dell
to was actually listening to what we're
talking about when he says leave the
Dave gentlemen soundbite please sir that
we talked about prior to the show where
he says we had to get him where yeah
where he said we had to get him and then
and again just listening to him tube
this is another part of the issue he
sounds like a good will hunting extra
yes which in New York City gives another
reason for suspect exactly like he's a
Manchurian general manager candidate
from Mike have I tap-dance long enough
for you to find that somebody get the
one well it doesn't actually say exactly
what you're saying he's he's the one
that was most excited about Doug the Pug
may young a draft choice were you
looking at a Doug the Pug video when I
but which one do you want there's three
one where he said that they had to get
him because they were there were two
other teams February or in the city
keeps going on any longer I'm close
gonna be around they're not labeled that
way why didn't you wait until 17 well I
know for a fact there were two teams who
would have taken them in front of 17 I
know that for a fact
so it's it Tom it's tough it really is
it wasn't it wasn't easy for me to pass
up Joshi Allen it was you know that for
me you know in my background that was
very very difficult but I think that
much of Daniel Jones
so how many Giants fans who can't I've
done with the Sklar brothers yeah how
many Giants fans who can't see straight
just because this guy opens his mouth at
all yeah thinks that he's referring to
last year's Josh Allen at the cool at
the cobalt know what he's talking about
means he's he's rude say Quan Barclay
what's he thinking I mean the Giants
have right every single time the Giants
friends are freaking it's just like
excuse me to say come on Barclay should
be freaking out more than you guys but I
mean what do we have like six more years
of Eli left is that what he's like after
it like posthumously play quarterback
for a while I just like the guy who's
like it is seventh year at a college and
you're like dude you can graduate and
just move on yeah and I know Eagles fans
who just wants you nice
I know Eagles fans Cowboys fans like TJ
who's on our set right yeah inject these
tears into their veins right now right
yeah just love it's life-giving well
especially Redskins fans who got the guy
that you know a lot of people were
saying before it classically Haskins
goes to a team in your division and you
don't think when I mean you saw the
video of Dwayne Haskins when he was
announced yes just laughing I know but
the fact that the any Washington [ __ ]
fan could actually feel they have a
moral drafting high ground guys to look
down and laugh at anyway they're
trophies in the case yes
first time since you know since Gibbs
left town well so where are you kidding
me
like almost so we were looking at the
video right here Haskins watching on the
phone and by the way he mails right now
and then just yeah good shot go ahead
sham yeah looks like that Alonzo
Mourning Jeff on he's being drafted this
is the biggest moment of a kid's life
and he can't even be bothered to take
the headphones all the way off it's
still a little bit partially on his ear
yeah he's DJ DJ he's a DJ in the middle
of that place if I had to give you a
choice yes the Sklar brothers here and
Jason Randy here too if you were getting
drafted what would this Sklar brothers
draft party look like first things first
I'd be wearing in 1990s NBA draft suits
29 foot down to my knees 29 buttons all
the way down maybe a cane maybe a top
hat could be a scepter alright that's
what I'm going up with me of I think the
band third base would be playing at our
dress okay where would it be held would
you have family I mean what's the spread
for Saints for us I think Vince Young
bought an Applebee's so I'd probably put
it at Vince Young's Applebee's okay
Vince is that friends family and then I
would have like just a couple random
people jut have them come and have got
people go like do they how do they know
like how do the sklar's know Oliver
Miller and and Dustin Diamond like hot
okay I don't know how they were going
either of those people are why are they
we're serving sea bass to sea bass
did you think you'd hear Oliver Miller
today coming full circle that is coming
full what's the dumb people town podcast
for those who may not know what that is
we believe that the world is getting
Dumber or Dumber is getting louder or
prouder okay off more like smart is like
a bunny rabbit and dumb is just petting
it just patting it to hard like
like see he doesn't like he's smiling
not he doesn't know that yeah and so we
take three crazy real true crime stories
of dumb people doing dumb things like
the woman who got her head stuck in a
tailpipe during a Country Music Festival
that woman so and then we break down all
the choices value and tried to fight his
own reflection in a bar window he keeps
moving where I'm moving my drunk guy
it's centage of stories from Florida
them a lot it's funny because we were
talking about Game of Thrones Game of
Thrones earlier which today is a day
that it can't kid I'm not saying they
okay if you were a kid and you were 12
and you didn't see Avengers end game
parents everywhere like don't talk to
anybody
do not talk to you not as a friend in
the eye they were livin it for you if
you're an adult and you did not see Game
of Thrones last night you're going to
work today going do not look at the
internet don't talk to anybody so I
don't watch the show I missed out cuz my
had my daughter like right around when
it was starting and we were too tired
and right I should get on board
so Randy watches it so Randy and I like
to sit around and play a game he says
something and I have to decide if it's
something that happened in Game of
Thrones or it happened in Florida at a
show a bunch of people sitting around
getting drunk with a dwarf a guy who
hooked up with his sister two takes a
giant sword and knights a tall woman
Westeros or floor that and Westeros or
West Palm
we're do that jason has to answer did
that have any game with those I think
that happened in Florida that actually
happen in game a woman whose Dragon
accidentally or purposely burned down an
entire community definitely Game of
Thrones
that actually happened in Tampa there
was a my life that he doesn't even
understand it is amazing that I flew
home because you've got young kids you
know my children you guys okay
Brockman I flew home to be with them
right and I'm driving them to Hebrew
school okay yesterday fools got there
all right driving him there Susie took
the kids to see Avengers endgame
fighting yeah did they spoil it for you
you kept my oldest son know who I cannot
keep a secret blurts I won't say blurts
out whatever it has to be the biggest
spoiler of the filling and write to me
come on over it's a that was your
endgame and I try was my it was over
that's the endgame that's the Avengers
endgame just blurted it right out that's
like when you don't tell someone who's
kind of a friend of yours they'll mark
that you can't watch your game because
of whatever is happening and you have it
on the DVR they don't know you're like
I'm not watching this into later
situation and then they just text you
dude no way and you're like why did you
I didn't know you're not in my circle
don't text sports block out if you're
trying to really you really can't speak
to another human being this you cannot
have any roll back the clock to 1995 and
just be like highlights later that night
so I told my son I'm like do not do that
say this like I'm like you if you will
have friends in life that'll be so upset
with you know they won't tell you
secrets they won't tell you anything
I try to use this as a teachable moment
here though my voice was raising because
I was bad like I flew home and watch the
movie alright yeah I watched anything I
watched infinity Wars infinity war with
my kids yesterday just to get ready get
really yeah just get up for the thing
and then it like got too late and my
youngest daughter wanted to go out and
watch you know go see end game at like
8:00 I'm like this is a school night
it's gonna be done at 11:00 it's three
bills I was like this is gonna be so
late but part of me is like yeah let's
go and my wife just kept saying no
that's so cool and I had to then stand
behind my wife and be like yeah that is
kind of irresponsible the way we could
make it if we can get the
irresponsibility debate done we still
could make Twitter and Instagram check
out the dumb people town podcast you
guys are welcome here any love you [ __ ]
this show love you guys thanks for
having us what's the website people go
to you super scarce calm it's got all of
our tour dates and come see us we'll be
coming near you we have our dates almost
all the way through the end of the year
so please do check out the Sklar
brothers on again Twitter and Instagram
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on VR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app